peu
[Musique]
chat france je m'adresse à toi toi qui
m'a tout donné
toi que j'ai aimé choisi est servi toute
ma vie pendant des années j'ai combattu
en tournant la corruption les lobbys et
les injustices
je suis donc une candidate différente
des autres
je suis fier de prendre la suite de rené
dumont et de son verre d'eau vous
défendre l'écologie
à quoi sert de produire plus si c'est
pour vivre moins bien en détruisant les
équilibres naturels la faune la flore
l'air la terre et la mer
les gouvernements qui se sont succédés
prisonniers du même modèle productiviste
ont tous fait et refait les mêmes
serrures sous couvert de renouer avec la
croissance
ils sont creusé la dette et non rien
anticipé ni les risques majeurs du
dérèglement climatique ni le
développement de pollution et la
mauvaise qualité des aliments qui cause
la multiplication des maladies chère
france depuis cinq ans
chez miles de voie défiguré à la
division abîmées par le mensonge et la
corruption
menacés par les pollutions qui
détruisent notre santé la parole raciste
s'est banalisé au plus haut sommet de
l'état
les retraites ont été mises à mal le
grenelle de l'environnement a été
piétiné le chômage a augmenté
quel sera l'avis de nos enfants si nous
ne faisons pas le bon choix
si nous ne prenons pas d'urgence et
bonne décision
nous n'avons plus le temps d'attendre
le vrai changement c'est l'écologie seul
un programme de transformation
écologique de nos modes de production et
de consommation peut sortir notre pays
de la crise que nous traversons pour
créer des emplois pour aider les pme
innovantes nous engagerons d'urgence la
transition écologique
je lutterai contre le bétonnage et
l'étalement urbain
je préserverai notre biodiversité
je veux changer de politique énergétique
qu'on ne vienne pas me dire que le
nucléaire est sans danger à fukushima
j'ai vu des mères pleurer
car ils ne savaient pas comme à faire
pour nourrir leurs enfants sans lait
contaminé chère france
je veux défendre les droits de chacun
les personnes de même sexe pourront se
marier et adopter les sans papiers
seront régularisés l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes sera enfin
respectée chez air france je crois que
l'europe est ton avenir
je proposerai à nouveau traité européen
au construire enfin une europe fédérale
et solidaire madame monsieur vous êtes
la france
je vous propose de reprendre les choses
en main ensemble
rien de grand ne se fait sans courage
rien de juste ne s'accomplit sans
résistance
vive l'écologie vive la république et
vive la france
[Musique]